y atrás es lo que quiero contar esta
historia es bastante sencilla viene del
interior y comienza un día que andrés un
amigo mío de que habíamos compartido
muchos muchos años de goles y muchos
años de jóvenes jugando juntos me llama
y bueno porque nos hicimos en el update
de que era de nuestras vidas y tanto
tiempo que no nos veíamos ahí empezó a
develar su verdadera intención como
siempre estás un chamaquito en una
intención por suerte no fue videollamada
hasta ahí no la conocía
y me dicen mira ya me estoy yendo de mi
trabajo de toda la vida es trabajé en el
estado como sabes me estoy yendo toda la
vida de este trabajo estamos armando una
empresa importante con un grupo de
socios así que vos que sabes
te quiero pero si me puede dar una mano
en todo lo que tenemos que tener en
cuenta cuando hacemos la empresa para no
equivocarnos porque la verdad no estamos
perdidos
esa fue la conversación digo por suerte
no era videollamada porque no pudo ver
la cara sobre todo cuando se activa el
sistema inmunológico cuando escucho vos
que sabes
me imagino hay que es como lo que deben
pensar o sentir el caballo cuando el
jinete lo acaricia y me parece que están
por montarme que voy a tener un peso en
el lomo que hasta recién no tenía esa
misma sensación me genera cuando te
dicen vos
este bosque sabes pero inmediatamente
hay la verdad que andrés mi amigo además
de mi amigo me dijo una expresión que
pensar más siempre y me debilita que es
me puede dar una mano me puedes ayudar y
ahí que hay en la trampa de andrés más
claramente y además le dijo estamos
perdidos digo primero andrés sí te puedo
aportar en algo encantado pero vas a lo
largo mira que no por ahí no sé si vos
tenés claro lo que te estás metiendo lo
que va a haber que hacer para crear una
empresa de cero y amable y ser exitoso
no te preocupes nosotros tuvimos leyendo
un montón de libros seis un montón de
cursos los mismos todos los vídeos
tenemos un montón de pdf quédate
tranquilo
bueno entonces tan mal de cero no
arrancamos por lo menos todo lo que haya
publicado
andrés y su equipo lo de saben así que
bueno quedamos parados en un lunes a las
6 de la tarde en mi oficina y ahí hay
vino andrés ese día con sus amigos y
llegaron allí a mi oficina y empezamos a
hablar yo dice bueno vale vamos a hablar
de empresas como quedamos 2000 andrés ya
que hubo tuviste la delicadeza de
trabajar mi agenda con un pedido basado
en que nos conocíamos de tantos años del
voley yo estuve una sorpresita ya que le
hicieron tantos libros y si vienen de
los vídeos y están perdidos vamos a ir
por otro camino yo quería hacer acordar
todo lo que nosotros dos aprendimos
juntos sobre empresas mientras jugábamos
al voley y tal vez no nos dimos cuenta
y así entonces empezamos a recorrer esos
temas que yo le conté a ellos creo que
catorce encuentros abstenciones tengo
que contar en 14 minutos con lo cual ahí
le pido perdón para hacer un poquito
plano en algunos temas pero me interesa
ser amplio ser ancho y por ahí no tan
profundo y además traerles un mensaje
que no sólo para empresas porque ustedes
trabajan o estudian
no trabajan y estudian
o viven o menos viven en cualquiera de
los tres casos en una cantidad enorme de
valores y de cuestiones que vienen del
deporte les van a servir en esos tres
ámbitos así que si están acá en alguno
de los tres de las tres categorías están
y apuesto que a que les vayan a servir y
así entonces empezamos con andrés y con
su equipo sin familia que yo no saben
nada de goles no importa
todos jugamos alguna vez al vóley de
alguna manera o no si en la playita de
la facu en el pasto en la cancha
competimos alguna vez tuvimos unidad lo
que es que la pelota venga volando pero
digo si no importa no tienen que saber
de goles igual yo me voy a encargar de
mirar primero acéptame de la primera
analogía tiene que ver con esta esa que
tanto vimos y conocí muy sufrimos y
disfrutamos cuando jugábamos de chicos
este déjame que te cuente otra manera no
te la voy a hacer repensar vamos a hacer
que esa pelota que tanto conocemos en el
mundo empresario en el mundo en el que
te estás por meter a andrés y equipo es
un tema un problema o una oportunidad en
las empresas en organizaciones en la
familia en los emprendimientos los
profesionales han dado más o menos
siempre enroscados en alguna de estas
tres cosas y bueno a ver cómo podemos
hacer con la pelota aceptaron ahí andrés
en su equipo la analogía y ahí
arrancamos así que arrancó con ustedes a
ver si les puedo dejar este esa misma
enseñanza de lo que aprendimos con eso
les parece vamos bien
primero aprendimos a entender el juego
temprano que es que es eso el que se
entender el juego temprano vieron cuando
dice no entendió el partido
el deporte no entendió el negocio le fue
mal porque no entendió el negocio es en
que te estás metiendo para eso
vas a tener que visitar del lado de
empresa que es aquel dónde estoy medio
yo de empresario vas a tener que tener
una enorme cantidad de fundamentos
técnicos que son los que te van a dar
vida a la empresa a algo te vas a
dedicar y tienes que manejarlo bien y
andrés no entendía nada y solo amigos
menos me gusta acordar el tiempo que
estuvimos aprendiendo a pegar de arriba
golpear de abajo hasta que el saque
bloqueo los fundamentos básicos del
deporte para color después llevarlo a la
competencia no empezamos de entrada
compitiendo estuvimos manejando una
serie de fundamental de cuestiones
básicas para el poder después hacer la
transición al juego entonces en la
empresa va a necesitar lo mismo va sense
en esa cuestión inicial para poder tener
éxito en el resto porque después vienen
la asignación de roles y funciones bueno
yo como decía la introducción tuve la
oportunidad mi vida de ver miles de
empresas
si algo que me complica entender cuando
llego es esto
que haces bien acá adentro o vos bien
que haces porque haces bien es más
amplia
a veces me encuentro muy bien a qué te
dedicas y por ahí no está definido
alguien que tiene que vender al final
del 80% del día no vende el que tiene
que gerenciar el 90% del día no gerencia
y el que tiene que no sé qué manejar en
el 70% del tiempo no maneja pero sus
roles están en esos nombres entonces
definir bien eso como teníamos en el
voley que además rotas saben que el
voley dice rota pasa por todas las
posiciones aprendes a jugar y estás es
especialista en algunas después cuando
jugás mejor ya te dejan medio fijo en
una volea avanzados y esto lo puedes ver
otro por dios que no perdones
y una cosa importante que aprendimos en
el boli es cuando es para mí este tema
este problema esta oportunidad que viene
volando cuando es mi cuando es tuya la
va a dejar pícara y nos van a mirar si
tú ya tú ya no es tener la barra de
bonos tuviera nombre no era de nadie y
en la empresa te va a pasar cada cinco
minutos no es de nadie en temas o al
contrario me cruzo y era de otro
entonces la tiró la tribuna y me hago y
me hago culpable encima entender bien
cuando ese tema cuando esa oportunidad
que les está pasando por enfrente cuando
ese problema es de uno eso me lo dio el
voley y también quien me sigue en la
acción el lugar y es un deporte
totalmente en proceso después del que
recibe bienes de arma después del que
arma bien el que ataca hasta ahí son
compañeros míos se la tengo que dar de
la mejor manera aunque sólo haya
recibido mancha tengo que mejorar el
proceso de darse lo mejor para que haya
éxito en el juego y si pensamos eso la
empresa
estaría bueno pero si el otro es el
exponente el próximo punto es el
oponente se lo tengo que dar lo más
complicada posible y eso también el boli
me lo dio como aprendizaje y así
empezamos a ver en qué cosas el factor
tiempo en el volumen en el tiempo que
tenemos el boli para tomar una decisión
este
este es el tiempo que tenemos para tomar
decisión hasta que se nos caiga el
problema hasta que la oportunidad
desaparezca hasta que el tema explote
hasta que nadie lo quiera agarrar esa es
todo el tiempo entonces aprendes el
sentido de urgencia bien vista lo que
está siempre incendiado en la empresa no
podemos hacer nada estamos siempre
apurado sentido de urgencia de que las
cosas no pueden dormir yo en el voley no
me la puedo guardar no la puedo tener
como en otros deportes no me la puedo
llevar solo la tengo que jugar así como
la recibe lo tengo que pasar tengo un
sentido de urgencia y una necesidad de
fluir en el juego y no ser un obstáculo
entendés andrés no ser un obstáculo en
la empresa a veces llegan los temas y es
en el escritorio de quien cayó la store
vida te da y no va a salir ese no está
haciendo fluir en el juego y va a ser
claro que si lo sea y qué pasa si me
demoro en el voley en la empresa punto
para el punto en contra punto para el
otro cae no tengo tiempo infinito no
todos los deportes son así piénsenlo
hay muy pocos deportes en que el tiempo
o la ley de la gravedad es tu peor
enemigo el gol en medio eso a entender
que las cosas no tienen tienen que pasar
en forma rápida y hay que operar
permanentemente parece que al planificar
y hay que planificar sí y después de
planificar el bueno y parece de afuera
totalmente desordenado y anárquico pero
sin deportes es súper ordenado está todo
planificado cuando lo entender igual que
la empresa cuando la entender está todo
ordenado y hay sistemas y hay procesos
que no los vamos a ver y otra cosa que
tiene ese deporte que me enseñó una
enseñanza clave para la empresa es que
pasas de ataque a defensa todo el tiempo
o no les pasa todo el tiempo tienes una
estrategia porque ahora la tenéis voz y
tenía que hacer el punto al otro y a los
tres segundos que pasó el otro lado y no
fue punto bien al revés y tenía que ser
totalmente defensivo y hacer todo lo
contrario sino reaccionar te lleva
puesto el oponente en el voley en el
mercado en el mundo corporativo lo ven
si aprendimos del proceso y sistemas
ojalá todos jugarán al voley un rato
para aprender proceso a ab v ac sea de y
esperar del otro algo yo puedo saber
dónde me la tiene que dar mi compañero
tengo que ser previsible dentro del
equipo y hacia afuera la suma del
proceso genera un sistema y un sistema
genera el adn de una empresa o de un
equipo jugar a algo fugaz a eso y te has
es conocido por eso y también esa
transición instantánea que les comento
recién cuando tengo una cuando un ataque
en voley estoy aprovechando una
oportunidad y generó una acción e
inmediatamente cuando me atacan estoy
disimulando una debilidad y genera una
reacción eso es una riqueza que en el
mundo corporativo es clave para la
dinámica del negocio se entiende ahí
vamos entonces andrés hasta ahí y va
tratando de entender y decimos no es
nada de libros
esto es todo de juego porque los libros
lo puedes tener solo para eso tiene que
estar muy entrenado porque en el voley
decidiesen un flash decidís en un
instante no tenés tiempo de nada cuando
la recibirá tenés que saber a quién se
la vas a dar
nos obligaría a todos los empresarios a
pasar por este deporte
es un ratito nomás y además y esto lo
obligaría al mundo educativo a pasar por
esto aquí en lo que aprendes lo aplicas
no aprendes cosas por aprender lo que lo
que entrenaba si lo usas inmediatamente
entonces tenés el sentido de juego en
ese sentido que las dos cosas se
retroalimentan lo que aprendiste te
sirve y lo que practicas tt ayuda
incorporas por acción ahora pasó todo
junto y juegas en equipo juegas en
equipo yo no no puedo aunque haya una
estrella aunque es el mejor jugador
aunque ser el mejor jugador no puede
jugar solo en el voley necesita el resto
no puede venir la pelota yo ataco bien
el siguiente y atacó no se lo tengo que
dar son tres toques necesito del otro el
mejor del mundo necesita del otro es un
proceso cuando necesito del otro aprendo
a jugar realmente en equipo que nos
llenamos la boca hablando de equipo en
las empresas pero funcionando realmente
el equipo después bueno queremos salvar
solo acá nadie se salva solo estás
obligado a pasarse la otro y estás
obligado a necesitas del otro que esté
bien que le vaya bien que se entrene
como vos necesitás el mismo compromiso
del otro el mismo que le estás poniendo
y también necesitas algo interesantísimo
que obligaría a las empresas a antes que
nada a trabajar este tema mi experiencia
me lleva a ver que el 70 80 por ciento
de los problemas que hay en las empresas
al final son de comunicación no son del
negocio en sí no son el producto del
proceso son de comunicaciones y entre la
comunicación entre las personas internas
en el voley tenemos una expresión cuando
eran más chicos que eran mal yo la
conocen ahora es mala me ha evolucionado
más la mía es lo mismo
comete un error se me cae la pelota lo
reconozco me hago cargo te desvinculó
del error y te doy la sensación de que
estamos jugando el equipo que la próxima
me voy a ocupar es un mensaje que en las
empresas yo no veo mucho en la presencia
noche fue error mío disculpen las
pésimas lo voy a ser mejor y en otros
deportes
se pierde en 40 tuvimos suerte
y fundamentalmente esa camiseta que está
allá atrás que es real es una camiseta
vieja y encima que tengo guardada y no
guarde el resto de las remeras más de
gisa porque no es una remera es la
camiseta del equipo con la que había una
de las con las que había jugado y ha
transpirado había ganado perdido he
llorado y reído dado vueltas olímpicas y
las tengo guardadas y como un tesoro no
me la toquen porque realmente es el
sentido de pertenencia que genera
cualquier grupo de personas que no es
una agrupación que tiene un fin en común
un objetivo en común que trabaja para
eso que se entrega y que genera
compromiso es vestirse y vivir la
camiseta en el voley y en la empresa aes
andrés estaba más tranquilo porque pensó
que el estupefaciente que yo había
tomado al principio no me había hecho el
efecto que le esperaba y ahora si tenían
que ver los dos temas y aprendimos cosas
que en argentina nos vendiera un
fenómeno como entender que las reglas no
las puedo acomodar ya están hechas juego
con ese reglamento o no juego no puedo
aplicar una parte del reglamento como
nos gusta a nosotros que hay una
autoridad que respetar que no habla de
dictadura autoritarismo
una dictadura en la nada es reconocer
una autoridad del árbitro de los jueces
de línea del autor
aplicación del docente del profesor del
entrenador es autoridad que le da un
orden al equipo en las empresas
a veces centro y me va un mes para saber
quién es el dueño no está tan claro ni
una autoridad o si hablas entre pares
siempre parece ser el otro y después del
liderazgo que hoy se habló ya acá que es
otra cosa en el liderazgo
tuve la oportunidad de ser capitán de mi
equipo muchas veces y no era el mejor
jugador del equipo el liderazgo tiene
que ver con una referencia de cuando
todo el mundo se pierde de cuando
tuvimos un mal día de cuando no sabemos
bien qué hacer añade una referencia para
mirar y decir bueno es por ahí vamos por
acá no estamos todo perdido adentro y
afuera de la cancha
si hay líderes dentro y fuera ven la
cantidad de analogías que hay en muchos
deportes el voley que en algunas más se
las peleó a cualquiera porque no las
tiene en otros deportes algunos son de
equipo como el voley pero no tiene el
problema del tiempo otro es sobre la
competencia que me da el voley que es
enorme primero la ventaja de
reconocerlas en general nosotros tenemos
la falta de humildad en 100 no existe
no existen los matamos
lo primero que hay que hacer lo
contrario reconocerla si existe hace
algo mejor que nosotros el otro equipo
en el voley también lo mismo y el voley
es un juego interdependiente yo no hago
lo que quiero depende mucho de lo que
hace el otro
si yo nado el que nada hay agua yo nado
acá me gana o yo le gano pero las
brazadas no impacta en mi juego en el
del voley y en de las empresas también
lo que hace mi competencia impacta en lo
que yo hago y lo que yo hago impacta mi
competencia y compito hasta el final
porque se juega por puntos
yo puedo el 23 a 0 y perder si me relajo
no es por tiempo no hay diferencia
definitiva siempre hay que estar online
para poder pelear y llegar hasta el
final y finalmente que no somos enemigos
ojalá los tendidos en todos los deportes
y así seguimos recorriendo temas y hoy
los pasos muy rápidos pues les dije que
daba para horas tuvimos que medir a
aprender que en el bueno y ahora se mide
todo pasar de la subjetividad a la
información para poder competir en otras
ligas para poder crecer para poder medir
y mejorar no es que me parece que está
jugando mal tengo las estadísticas que
está jugando mal y te voy a cambiar si
voy a trabajar esa debilidad que tuviste
y este es un punto clave de aceptar la
imperfección aún cuando ganemos partidos
aún
ambos torneos rara vez yo recuerdo habré
ganado 25 a 0 que es el mayor valor que
puede tener un set son 25 puntos no
menos 25 a 0 gana 25 a 20 y este
fenómeno se te hicieron 20 puntos ya
cometiste 20 errores o tuviste mente
imperfecciones fenómenos el tema
despegar más de las que ramos
en las empresas en las materias en el
estudio en el peronismo pasa lo mismo no
hay que pegarles a todos ni los mayores
deportistas vecinos ni los mejores ni
los más grandes glorias lo hicieron sólo
basta con aceptar la mayoría y así
aprendimos de todo ahora lo cierro
pensando en que andrés ahí traer otra
persona eso que me estás contando me
está sirviendo pero me falta lo último y
luego andrés la gran diferencia en
cualquier cosa que hagas vida
emprendedorismo familia estudio lo que
sea la vas a hacer con actitud la
actitud se va a compensar cualquier
brecha porque nunca una excusa nos hizo
ganar un partido cualquier con buena que
tú vas a compensar las debilidades que
tenga tu equipo con buena actitud vas a
hacer la diferencia vas a hacer un
equipo distinto vas a pasar de víctima
de protagonista del escritor de la
realidad actor vas a cambiar desde la
acción y así que ahora quiero hacer el
único artículo que me quisiera llevarme
un contrato de corazón que quiero hacer
con ustedes y que les invito a que
cuando les llegue la próxima oportunidad
el próximo tema la próxima pelota el
próximo problema
ustedes me prometan que se la pasará en
el siguiente
mejor de lo que lo habían recibido
yo esta oportunidad se la mostré le
expliqué que rápidamente que envuelve y
no me la puedo guardar así que me voy se
la dejó picando
[Aplausos]